mesdames et messieurs bonsoir le retour
de la star nicolas anelka accueilli
comme un roi au parc des princes
l'international français a été acheté à
un prix d'or pour un peu plus de 215
millions de francs
l'ex attaquant du réal de madrid a signé
un contrat de sept ans avec le psg après
son départ il y a trois ans les
supporters n'ont pas caché leur joie de
retrouver leur idole antoine marguet
quand nicolas anelka revient au psg
c'est une véritable star que l'on
accueille lunettes de soleil et
discrétion habituelle anelka par le feu
il faut dire que l'on parle beaucoup
pour lui ce retour chez lui a été long
et coûteux pour le psg anelka signe pour
215 millions de francs et 7 ans mais
surtout il revient près des siens
à 21 ans il va pouvoir commencer à
s'amuser une envie de vivre dont le psg
espère qu'elle décuplera le talent d'un
anelka tout neuf quand j'étais à londres
et à madrid
je m'occupais pas trop après les
fonctionnements
hélas
j'espère que j'aurai des choses à faire
après coup nicolas a hâte de retrouver
sa banlieue c'est annie et surtout la
ligue des champions qui lui réussit ans
mais il faudra encore attendre au moins
deux semaines pour voir jouer la star de
semaine de préparation avec son nouvel
entraîneur
ce soir la mi temps du match amical psg
karachi nicolas est venu saluer les
supporters du club parisien
et
désormais nicolas anelka va préparer sa
saison au psg pour convaincre il devra
marquer ou être décisif histoire de
rassurer les sponsors qui ont mis la
main au porte monnaie pour le retour au
parc du prince et ce soir